we mhm Maisie come on in hello of course
from shameless the season continues on
Sunday we're just enjoying the fact that
Trump misspelled hamburger there for the
grace of God go I yeah yeah I'm a
terrible speller do you always worry
about that when you're like you know
what I can't make fun of the president
for writing hamburgers because at some
point in my life I could end up also
writing hamburgers yeah except the part
about making fun of the president I do
feel like I can make you you can good
you're an American yeah that's his job
to me made fun of right but there's
really no way to do it we're looking at
there's no way to do it worth you know
sometimes your phone will spell correct
things you know it happens I've told a
lot of girls to suck my sock but a
hamburger there's no way to do it unless
you actually think it's spelled ber yeah
especially that first syllable of burger
we were like okay because hamburger it's
not like he just threw the D in its BER
instead of B you are and there doesn't
appear to be a connection between the E
and the u keys all right I'm gonna say
he knows how to spell hamburger that
looks like a typing error you think so I
hope so remains to be seen you hope so
remains to be seen well welcome William
HMAC I mean lovely to be here did you
miss me I was here about a year ago we
had yes we pushed very hard to get you
back here we were you you were very
booked and we made special requests we
missed you a lot well I'm a big cheese
you are that's right
especially when I saw I was watching the
Golden Globes and I was like not only
hey not only is William H Macy start
shameless and all this other film but
now he's taking the Cindy Crawford role
as the spokesman for Pepsi that's right
here the guy that was a good commercial
yeah did you see that I ain't saying
it's huge it's it's such production
values it tells a whole story in 30
seconds yeah it's like this epic alien
encounter commercial and I'm watching
going like I don't know what did it
William H Macy is the type of actor that
you're watching him in a Pepsi
commercial and he locks you into a
character in a Pepsi commercial in 30
seconds I was like I believe this
janitor was there a time where you
wouldn't do commercial OTT a lot of
performers don't want to do commercials
was there Tommy
no I won't to him totally there was a
line in the sand and you know I sort of
credit Alec Baldwin there he's the first
guy that stepped over and said yeah I'll
do it on camera commercial and I'm glad
I'm glad there's his it's a lucrative
market I would love to do more yeah I do
voiceovers I still do a lot of
voiceovers that's that's a good gig to
do you doing for commercials or for like
you know animations both animations
really tough that's a that's a lot of
work especially a big film I mean it's a
two three year process
commercials are great why is the
voice-over so tough for animation
because people want to believe that it's
like the greatest gig ever you show up
in your pajamas you read some lines you
go home but it's not that mmm it's a
long long long process write rewrite
rewrite again it goes and goes and goes
and you know the it's one of the things
one of those things where they're
writing but they also want you to sort
of ad-lib the things and then they take
that and then they go off and reanimate
you think of the process I mean right
you ad-lib something that means the the
people who draw the thing have to go
back and do more work so you're actually
watching it drawn before you actually do
the yeah yeah it starts way way early
and I guess the thing with the animation
that must drive people crazy is that the
process never necessarily has to be done
unless you're yeah aside from deadlines
because when you're shooting you don't
want to get the whole cast back together
and have to reshoot and do a whole bunch
of stuff but with animation you just get
these poor artists to keep drawing and
keep drawing and keep drawing there's
pressure to get things finished as long
as you've got your production team
together boy the money's just dripping
away and right it's expensive okay yeah
but it's I love animation I love doing
voice work it's big part of what I do
yeah it seems like like like even though
it's a lot of work it still seems like
more fun than showing up and having to
just on-camera stuff there's so much
pressure this just seems just a little
less pressure are you talking about like
having to figure out what to do with
your hands yes I am it's an excellent
question what do you I know I know what
I do am i right one
but I'm acting and I don't know what to
do yeah don't do that no that's the
scene calls for stir unless the
character that movie what about TV like
when you start now I think it's a
no-brainer that everybody I mean there's
so much quality TV out there but when
shameless first started it wasn't a
given the movie stars would just go into
TV right like was there any sort of
thing in your head where you go I have
to figure out where my positioning is or
were you smart enough to know that this
is a great script this is going to be a
great show this is gonna be good a lot
of things happened at once independent
film was my bread and butter I did a lot
of that stuff with the occasional big
film and the with the financial crisis
the independent film market just dried
up and television was ascendant at the
time and I saw the writing on the wall
so it took about two years to find
shameless but I knew I wanted to do it
and boy I chose well I in my opinion the
best and the brightest are working in
television the best stuff being done
anywhere yes being done in television
yeah what do you think changed that
because for a long time it was like
movie stars like the TV like your career
is finished if you go and do TV that's
right
what changed is the financial paradigm
there's so many outlets that want to
show their work and so everybody's
working they they need product and try
to rent a soundstage in LA everybody is
working there's not enough time to watch
all the great shows right it's there's
not enough hours in the day do you kind
of get amazed just the way people
process TV now like there are plenty of
people there going like oh shameless
like you'll be in here plugging the
second half of season 9 and it will
encourage half the audience to go you
know what let me start from season 1
it's a whole new world and I applaud it
it's good also stories are getting told
that we never would have heard I mean
back in the old days when there were
three networks you needed multiple
millions of people to tune in every day
every week to keep that show on the air
now a million people can keep a show
running
and that means stories that are really
sort of marginalized stories unusual
stories can get told and told in detail
and that's good because now you can turn
on the television and find your story
yeah another thing happens with
podcasting too where it's like you can
actually target niche audiences now you
can go to specialized people where you
can you can do this stuff that there's
an audience for yep
but when you've only got like you said
three networks or even when you just
have basic cable yeah you're too busy
trying to hit the mainstream to hit
those specific you know core audiences
yeah it's um I sort of am build Vivint
about the the new the new social media I
mean so much of it is tripe I feel like
I worry about my kids being on their
phones all the time I worry about people
writing all this drivel they're not
saying anything they're just texting all
the time it's not all good but I know
two things one the more people that get
to speak up the better and two you can
never put these things back in a bottle
once the corks out right going away you
want out people though that going back
in gravity ship people said when they
were 16 like especially like athletes
like I tweeted this 14 and 15 it was
like why are we looking at what you
wrote when you were 15 years old who
cares there's a there's a shift on which
I like which is if you're gonna write it
put your name on it and I like that like
not keeping things anonymous yeah yeah
do the anonymity bug you yeah it
encourages people to be [ __ ] to say
vicious things that they would never say
to your face that they would never say
with their name on it it's cowardice
Yonder I think we got a hold these
people accountable I'm reading this
amazing book called haywire about why
Americans can will believe anything
they'll believe they believe stuff which
is so clearly not true and how can this
happen and he he goes through 200 years
of American history and how we started
the country sort of rejecting the church
and started our own church and that just
opened the doors for some pretty crazy
beliefs as the creative process in
shameless changed as as the times have
changed because the world
a completely different place than when
you guys started and you deal with a lot
of topics that aren't the most sensitive
things in the world on the show do you
know I don't know if you're a part of
the writers room but but do you find
that the content has shifted to go you
know what we can't really I can't really
go down that road anymore I don't want
to push that envelope anymore because
it's just gonna be trouble no I've been
in the writers room I did I wrote one
about halfway through around No season
five with my writing partner Steven
Schachter so I got to sit in the writers
room and I got to say no to your
question I I think they're pretty clear
John wall's is a brave guy there's
nothing that's off the table for us
that's great nothing did you like
sitting in a writers room and writing or
did you hate it man it was the most
amazing thing I've ever seen to see how
a season gets born twelve episodes of a
season it was amazing and I was my
respect for John Wells quadrupled when I
saw how he was able to run the room so
that everybody felt free to say anything
mhm absolutely anything and there was
some really coarse stuff said but this
is men and women sitting together and
the rule was you can say anything and
inevitably someone would say something
and it was so disgusting everyone would
go oh god you should be ashamed of
yourself for saying that and laugh laugh
laugh and then there's a pause and you
say but you know what you could do there
you go I'm gonna sound like you're
leaving going like by the way now we
know he's a bad person
yeah you know we're all obsessed with
Boogie Nights so every time you hear we
have to ask you about it did you have
any kind of relationship with Burt
Reynolds mmm not close no I was scared
of him he's and then he's an intense guy
I made a joke one time which he found
singularly unfunny and for a second I
thought is he gonna throw a punch at me
yeah he had that reputation what was the
joke
oh I was being an [ __ ] and he was
saying something about what we do on
Smokey and the Bandit and
sort of mumbled well we know how that
turned out and bombed I laughed
you know don't I just say the stupidest
things will you say in a bad way because
I made a lot of money it made a fortune
yeah I'll take it
wish I'd directed it so he was a little
he was a little I didn't become close no
I know Paul had a rough time with him he
sort of turned on the film right after
it was out and said some terrible things
and then he ends up getting nominated
for it and put his career back on on
track so he came around on the film
after he got the well I guess yeah
somebody will do something and not think
that they did well or that it was a good
project and then I think anybody else
looks at it like that was a phenomenal
movie everyone in that was great
well we're back to the Internet be
careful what you say cuz everybody's
gonna hear it yeah yeah how do you
monitor it like how old are your kids 17
and 18 it's almost 17 and 18
how have you I guess it's a little
easier next they're a little older and
more mature but how have you kind of I
don't know if monitoring them is the
right word but trying to teach a
fourteen and fifteen year old how to
post things on social media like the
idea of this is gonna last forever when
you're 15 16 17 18 it doesn't make sense
well that's a good phrase to start with
this is gonna last forever so be careful
what you put on there you can't ever get
it off and it's not the seven it's you
got to start I mean kids of seven and
eight or on social media and there's no
nothing to do there are a lot of schools
that are paperless now all their
assignments are are electronic and and
there's nothing to be done we're not
going backwards that's the way it's done
so online Felicity found a contract and
we had him sign a contract of contract
of when they could use their phones how
they would use social media and what the
rules would be and what the penalties
would be if they broke the contract and
that really helped we also kept them
away from our business as long as we
could we just
we didn't talk about it we didn't take
him into any of those things so they
were blissfully ignorant of what we did
for a living they were confused why
people would stop us - yeah a picture
taken with this but right do you guys
always take it or do you hate when you
with your kids and people ask it's
easier to take the picture it is yeah
people bother you when you're eating you
know I did draw a line there I said well
I'm eating with my family now could we
do this after we after the meal and
people are very nice they they just get
excited and kind of they're embarrassed
when they realize they just walked up
yeah miellyn they they'll back off yeah
I guess when you take a stand and go
like now I'm with my family right now
then it becomes a whole explanation in a
conversation it could be an argument
you're just like I'll just snap it and
let's keep moving
yeah yeah people are good I don't I
don't have a problem with that and I get
it I see I see an idol of mine and I'm
the same way I think oh Lord I who have
you worked with that you've been like
that around where you're like oh my god
this person is either in this movie or
directing this movie or whatever it is
it you know forgive me then not let me
not name names cuz the list is so long I
know l JT Walsh well god bless Jackie
what rest in peace he's one of those
guys who a lot of you who don't know his
name like but he's a face that you've
seen in everything always good yeah
always good a respective of the movie
he's in he's never bad yeah there have
been I'm still a GOG I saw Steve Carell
the other night and I have trouble
talking to him I think he is the bee's
knees
that's amazing especially because you
know you've been famous longer right you
are you already doing this when he
started to have his kind of rise and so
you're still a fan oh yeah the whole
industry and movie a real deal and my
daughters went crazy for the office so I
could I probably know the scripts better
than he did and the last couple of shows
to the office is uh it's a it's a lesson
and acting it's just stupendous and then
the film's he's done since then the guy
can do anything it's quite annoying when
you think of the nominee did he get
nominated for something no he deserves
to boy yeah
he's for deposits or something oh he was
fantastic
yeah he got criticized for that I
thought it was a very subtle wonderful
perform criticized why is that relax a
lot sure it was yeah yeah yeah I thought
that was great it was great yeah how do
people said he didn't do anything but
those are just people that don't know he
did yeah because you can't that story
doesn't require Steve Carell to be over
the top it's not exactly a comedy you
know yeah and there's that fabulous
moment where he says well my brother
can't be bought and Steve Carell looks
at him for ever and says huh it's yeah
if you if you wrote out what that scene
was it would be four pages of writing
yeah and he did it in a look it's
amazing yeah I don't I don't remember
the moment I remember liking the movie
is really good I've never really watched
the American office I've seen moments in
it American office is really good and it
ages really well too you could still
watch it now and you're like this is
this is a great it's gonna last a long
long long time yeah great writing great
acting great character is there any part
of you when you watch the office because
I I'll see like now the reason I think
it's gonna last so long is I'll watch my
four-year-old niece is watching the
reruns and I'm going like this is how I
watch The Simpsons when I was a kid now
I've memorized everything this is what
the office is gonna be do you ever go
like I wish shameless was a little bit
more available for kids because you
can't I mean I think shameless will be
around for a really long time because
the themes you know will last forever
but you probably can't get into it until
you're at least in your teens you
shouldn't get it well it is what it is
right what I've liked to have been in
the office you bet or well 30 rock
another one their groundbreaking there's
it's a new kind of comedy I find it's a
little bit presentational is that the
word you know it's the whole notion that
there's a that the camera is part of it
and it makes it a little presentational
little self-conscious it's a new kind of
comedy I mean dr. binary style almost
yes almost documentary yeah mockumentary
but still yeah I just watched this is
spinal tap on the airplane oh no graver
it holds up it's so great still if you
watch you have you watched a recent No
I've never actually seen the entire
mowjood as amazing yourself a favor
the problem of these shows that they're
all there we're all relying too heavily
now on the camera zoom like you don't
like like there's be an awkward moment
and then the camera just kind of zooms
in on the person it's like the awkward
zoom like now they're all doing that but
it was great when they first started
doing yeah yes it's just it's just too
much do you see the any of the Fargo
series yeah do you watch that and go
especially that first season where it
was kind of I mean I guess they're all
somewhat related but that first season
the thing comes up where it's related to
the film do you watch that with an
attachment to what you did or do you see
it completely separately
I watched it separately I you know it's
similar to the film because that area is
sort of the star of it you know that
Minneapolis st. Paul area and the
universe exists the universe and it's
it's an amazing they're amazing people
and it's it fits so well doing that kind
of comedy and I thought Billy Bob should
have paid them to do that he was so much
fun in that first season yeah he was
fantastic right but you didn't look at
that going like oh this is kind of my
universe that I was in you're know yeah
the other stories can be told they're
right I appreciated what they were doing
you didn't you were gonna become a vet
well it was at a point I thought yeah I
have a great relationship to animals and
my wife swears I was a dog in a former
life that may be because my
gastrointestinal but it turns out to be
a veterinarian they don't like butter do
you you got to go to school and learn
things and you know I want to do all I
know that's too much no I I get that
what do you do you have any concern over
the fact that this is it for emmy rossum
on shameless we lost Ian at the end I
guess the end of this first half of this
season in October from the show and now
Fiona's leaving and Emmy Rossum and you
were kind of the two linchpins I guess
of the show you guys were the
each side of the moral compass for a lot
of it does that concern you that she's
leaving yeah
is really sad it was very upsetting when
she said she was going to leave it's a
little frightening but yet on wells is
really good he says there's lots of
stories yet to be told and I wish her
well I totally understand why she's
leaving and she's got a big career I
mean she's gonna do great things she's a
wonderful actor mm-hmm but I'll still
miss her yeah do you get panicked about
leaving stuff like I would be panicked
to leave anything until it's absolutely
run dry because the idea yeah well
you're smart you're smart it doesn't
come around too often in this business
where that you're actually getting paid
so I'm gonna ride this horse all the way
to the barn yeah you probably should
could you see guys I mean there's a few
stories classical people that left
projects before they should have left
them no yet right what are you doing
yeah yeah stupid
I mean you wonder I mean you go back to
the office and Steve Carrell leaving the
office before that that that well had
been tap dry and your la he made it he
made a good decision did one year before
though like I think it was like two or I
think they went on two or three - yeah
he's good it was good he was really
scible and it was but I loved the last
season in that moment right that's a
very difficult decision I'm sure for him
to make big I I know it was tough for
Emmy too but she's newly married and she
wants to live in New York and she had
sold a pilot and she's got a lot of fish
to fry have you seen any of the scripts
or started shooting for season ten or
anything like that
nothing nothing you're just taking it on
good faith that there are these stories
that you claim there are good faith is a
good way to put it yeah back in the
early seasons John Wells and I would
have lunch and he would sort of sketch
out in 15 minutes where the season was
going to go and at a point I decided to
play it blind I thought it might be
better for me to not know where the
seasons going there's this whole thing
about the arc of the character well
that's a two-edged sword one of the
worst things an actor can do is start
acting the end rioting and it's very
difficult not to do that what do we try
setting it up because you know what's
coming ly exactly right um I did ER for
a while and they
they kept the writers and the the cast
separate so one never knew where the
thing was going and I had to fire George
Cloney I played the his boss had to fire
George and I thought I don't think
George is leaving the show wonder if the
seedings I'm leaving what could I do
except fire him so that he stayed fired
right that's better acting right right